dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir first of all
thanks so much for watching two minute
papers you fellow scholars have been an
amazing and supportive audience we just
started but the series already has a
steady following and I'm super excited
to see that it is also great that the
helpful and respectful community has
formed in the comment section it's
really cool to discuss these results and
possibly come up with cool new ideas
together in this episode we're going to
set foot in computer animation imagine
that we have built bipedal creatures in
a modeling program we have the geometry
down but it is not nearly enough to
animate them in a way that looks
physically plausible we have to go one
step beyond and define the bones and the
routing of muscles inside their bodies
if we want them to walk we also need to
specify how these muscles should be
controlled during this process this work
presents a novel algorithm that takes
many tries to build a new muscle routing
and progressively improving the results
it also deals with the control of all of
these muscles for instance one quickly
needs to discover that the neck muscles
cannot move arbitrarily or they will
fail to support the head and the whole
character will collapse in a very
amusing manner when talking about things
like this scientists often use the term
decrease of freedom to define the number
of independent ways a dynamic system can
live building a system that is stable
and uses a minimal amount of energy for
locomotion is incredibly challenging you
can see that even the most miniscule
change will collapse a system that
previously worked perfectly the fact
that we can walk and move around
unharmed can be attributed to the
unbelievable efficiency of evolution the
difficulty of this problem is further
magnified by the fact that many possible
body compositions and setups exist many
of which are quite challenging to hold
together while moving and even if we
solve this problem walking at a given
target speed is one thing
what about higher target speeds in this
work the resulting muscle setups can
deal with different target speeds
uneven terrain
and
other unpleasant difficulties
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time